non è quello ciao a tutti sono tornati
tu allora mistery box più grande che
abbia mai visto
la notizia è cibo vita resterà cui
mangia piaciuto ma non penso allora
visita a manthone è veramente enorme set
fatica fine facendo vedere tuttavia come
tipo esisteranno dentro limone di
talento ad essere usato per che spera di
trovare il tocco lato ma non penso
comunque lasciato un bel banche si può
anche vedere altre mistery box e
metteteli covoni preso un bel the
camilla biscotti patatine pop corn
perché in questo video sarà molto
interessante ed entrare una scatola c'è
un'altra scatola c'è una scatola dello
scalo romano che per ogni oggetto che
pescheremo potrete scrivere nei commenti
approvato o non hanno trovato in base
all
se mi piace sono mi piace inutile se è
divertente
sabato inizia iniziato
ecco il primo getto
c'è scritto che come viene visto la
ragazza che dice grazie per avere
comprato questa scatola misteriosa
sicuro che ti piaccia è tutto rivolto in
[Musica]
in paura allora ma c'è finta invisibile
gioco scientifico che mettiamo agente
chimico e byrne ex agente chimico acido
solforico al 10 per cento candela e
matita oddio vediamo si è rotto e fa
parte di giochi scientifici tra cui
lesioni ottiche che sono quelle che
trovate l'altro avvocato caleidoscopio
tinte visibili e riflessi multi quelli
tuttora in pratica con questo si può
scrivere un messaggio segreto nella
carta poi per rivelarlo asi
così parlando si iscrive poi per
rivelarlo basta accendere la candela e
si vedrà il messaggio segreto non
proviamo adesso altrimenti ip che
sarebbe già abbastanza non lo so che vi
piacciono altissimi video lo liberò
accorgiamo un bon bravo devi sapere se
volete che lo trovo e non è ricordiamo
gli esperimenti con queste cose le più
grandi star game labirinto ci sono delle
palline tocca palla usciva dalla b vinto
muovendo subito si è tremonti
posso giocare piano mi hanno preso fino
a un po allora la pallina
nascendo devi dire la meglio
eccolo aeree temi muoverlo per farla
celleno finissimo dove la fai andare
dove deve andare tra l'altro non so
forse deve tornare devi riuscire a
tornare indietro
dall'altra parte si passa l'istat fa
centrare quale la cimo non è facilissimo
via presso quel divertente un paesino
così essere all'astra anche perché sennò
non potevi bastare wow
daremo anche tutto il percorso tante
incastrato
no io sono un bravissimo con un mondo
presso il 3 ottobre
mi stavo vedendo ancora quasi una
certezza è che il prefetto non è
elettronico per niente operato calabresi
elettronico sistema come berlino perché
così semplice eppure si diverte scooter
mentre approvato bello è bello sì sì
molto blandi biagio ci siamo dimenticati
di dire quello di prima se ha approvato
stai bozzato io direi approvato perché
esperimenti
[Musica]
allora se non avete visto il mio altro
video di unboxing mistery box di amazon
non sapete ma questa l'avevano già
trovata in quella lista di boxe che era
da 50 euro
quindi questa regalerò comunque è molto
carina hello kitty telecomandato nello
scooter con il telecomando
anche questo un doppio piazzamento e di
quello delle illusioni ottiche
se volete vedere come sono andate a
vedermi altro video di mistery box di
auto abbiamo un national geographic 100
pezzi con due pinguini e il cucciolino
che così può farlo io tutto bene o
faccia qualcosa la terza programma che
ci permettiamo fa trovare in mezzo ma
piace comunque al molto carino io lo
trovo bene anch'io se mai approvato
non l'ho provata in piacciono i budget
questo è un po di carta bomber a bagno e
scorretta
a farle eco è pronto dei soldi facendo
la città noi abbiamo dei moti giganti
sono dieci è anche la mia ma ritorniamo
sembrano piccolina rispetto a te stai
grande nome la band sale marino alto
citrico olio lametta bicarbonato di
sodio cose fornire per le forme da un
bagno sono ormai pensavo fosse un po più
grandi ma guardate sono un po piccolini
quindi escono delle mini bambine e un
cucchiaino per miss chiarito cosa
preferito provare a fare il mondo e da
bagno quindi direi approvato non è vero
che funzioni però non l'abbiamo ancora
tesi nato perché potrebbe essere
divertente dai perché noi sentiremo una
prova una provato di incoraggiamento
allora si potevano capitare altre due
cose di questi kit ed era come fare il
sapone in casa e come farei balsamo
labbra in casa allora sinceramente mi
sarebbe piaciuto di più quello del
sapone perché ovviamente
spesso il modello budget però va bene
comunque
allora questo qua mi era capitato lo
stesso però mi era capitato l'albero ve
lo ricordate che era quello in cui
crescevano crescevano in crema tali però
in questo caso un pappagallo e mi piace
di più perché non è che io adoro i
pappagalli allora è molto carino perché
funziona voce anche calato funziona ed è
molto semplice da fare quindi io direi
ha provato
fateci sapere se volete che lo facciamo
in un video di garanzia o la gallina
queste le piume della gallina deve
toglierle le uova stanno dentro e non
devi fare ovviamente togliere le piume e
non devi far cadere la walt aspettiamo
questo pollo gigante che tutte le più
mente qui intorno
il gioco consiste che ognuno di noi deve
togliere una piuma senza far cadere uova
che sono all'interno non so se si vedono
sono delle uova incastrate quindi alla
fine vince chi almeno nuova il giocatore
quindi non c'è
non so perché ma perde la faccia di
questa carli ha infatti sempre o non era
ragazzi che ne pensate
e toccato la distrutto ok inizio io
credono più ma è accaduto niente
vai
niente
un altro uomo per evitare niente ma devo
stare attenta adesso è la parte più
difficile
niente tremo abbiamo niente stragi apre
il mio 2
niente devo per via di un nastro
vorrei perso perché no anche a te né
senza parlare e vienna
bravo presentato alla fine le ha mai
detto ne rimangono due è impossibile ma
comunque investito con tantissimo
un'altra cosa del vfb c'è scritto mondo
e del gioco della torre di non far
cadere la torre ea disegnata il manto
degli animali anche apriamo noi vediamo
un po come pd in pratica bisogna fare la
torre e non parla cadere certo ci sono
tutti i pezzi che da via più fredda la
torre
chi non lo so non lo vedo molto stabile
anche io che cosa facciamo cadere subito
comunque c'è anche il dato che bisogna
tirare che dice quali stecche togliere
prima quindi il manto dell'animale
sempre la cina qualche pardo alla zebra
oppure quelli di legno ok iniziato in
legno e poi perché avevo di la 1a solo
11 meno si sa dall'alto senza come voi
la vedo veramente pericoloso ma questo è
che fa legna queste ore è però tocca a
me
[Applauso]
ok allora no non è questo ma è sbagliato
numero
caratteristica forse pure aiutata hai
visto
non ci credo che sono fatte da far
cadere tutto tocca a me panda ha preso
secondo voi chi l'ha fatta avere to
legno nuovamente la minaccia presto un
altro bando che vedrà sembra penso ce
l'ha in chi è davanti ma è possibile qui
ho trattenuto il respiro jaffa questa da
gene è una lingua vale questa dei
giraffa o di essere talmente più
difficile zebra c'è un ora dopo la
fisica
si sa fa ho questa festa l'ho visto io
non so perché questo gioco mi ha anche
fatto che guarda così disse panda chiama
[Musica]
banda chiappa che difficile questo
queste giraffa anche un pure questo è
girato questa davanti se n'è anche una
card 8 neanche uno acqua milano proprio
di peters legno e dove sta non ci credo
che non cala e niente nuovo giraffa
sempre più difficili che farmaci di
massimo legno scorso c'è questo buffa
troppo piano piano sembra la zona ma
sulle cose libera panda quando proviamo
con questo nome uscito neanche un
ghepardo bizzarra legno se questo qui
questo consente al medio non so no
questo questo e questo qui l ha fatta
non ci credo panda bianca dai pregiudizi
ma insomma schierato just questa volta
vista che è finita
secondo questo qui forse riesco a
stabilizzarlo coperti giochi troppo che
di quello della calvizie giraffa una
crisi
[Applauso]
decisamente no provatelo ma la zucca
bellissimo vedere il parto una barca una
bacca fatta con le conchiglie ovviamente
una spesa di veliero ho fatto con le
conchiglie e gli stecchini apriamo lo
vediamo non sembra granché
vediamo un po congelato conti ma sono
queste conclude è una specie di il
modellatore per il collaudo a simona la
stellina le conchiglie per degli
scadenti tempo brutto questo modello di
barca sinceramente non ho però magari ad
alcuni piace non lo so fino a me non
piace ciononostante mi piace mi
piacciono questo girone era il
piazzamento e basket però con le
conchiglie lo zio che alla fine non
scrivete di voi per me e anche per me il
primo che non abbiamo trovato un altro
kit di bombe da bagno però questa volta
si è scritto cioccolato questo si mangia
tu chi continua ad aumentare
però questa
quelli che cosa sono con questa cellula
lamenta se questa è la menta menta
fragola e fragola e mela e attraverso
basalari cioccolato sono praticamente
uguali quindi in pratica queste sono e
lo stesso kit per ora sapori diversi
mannaggia potevano mettere un kit
diverso però quindi per me questo è il
claim è uno slide phone o clio uno slide
che frey e magari la possiamo rischiare
all'offline ma con la busta permuta con
cercare asi e tipo quella di crayola
ecco questa speciale lo slam senza
quella non si oppure ti manda tanti
possono costruire dei personaggi può
essere lasciate seccare si induriscono
governo non serviamo da di slang e
personaggi immagino di hello kitty una
persona di diano kitty i coniglietti i
bancari niente successo ma ne hanno
messi uguali non servono a niente e
abbiamo finito pure le ultime cose
perché ricordo fuoco
strano poi abbiamo altri flash led
colorati comunque le giallo blu
poi abbiamo altri due personaggi sempre
di hello kitty suppongo che due uguali
[Musica]
sono i due tappini quindi il resoconto
quali la cosa che ci ha più di questa
box ingegneri queste qua il mattoncini a
me la concedo
sì secondo me i mattoncini di sé
il kit delle bombe da bagno e funziona
anche labirinto è labili fera che i
nostri sudati vinta da supercar in user
questi due giorni ormai una vita più
bella peccato che sono state un filing
che mani ma anche le cose non abbiamo
provato il passo
secondo me è molto divertente anche
questo quindi il valore di 100 euro
c'era da solo 19 cose contano anche
questi personaggi di minuscoli quindi si
va a questo è molto costeranno 50
centesimi loro beni siano sono due euro
che penso che il costino di più ma noi
siamo il caldo non sapevamo queste cose
secondo voi se valore di 100 euro
vi è piaciuta questa mistery box da una
10 che botto di da te qual è la cosa che
mi piace dal in quella che mi è piaciuta
di meno e una villa sono qua 4 castelir
scoccare a boxing shopping altre mistery
box video di halloween click quella che
preferite e la buona visione